bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors le
ministère la santé qui organise cette
soirée ce soir au grand palais pour
remercier les personnels de la santé
mobilisés lors de la crise sanitaire
qu'en pensez vous écoutez je pense que
c'est une bonne chose ça fait toujours
plaisir de recevoir ceux qui l'invitent
à sion et je pense que ça fait partie
des comment dire des der garde et des
actions que doit mener le gouvernement
pour essayer de 2,2 de remercier le
personnel soignant qui s'est investi et
qui continue à s'investir pour cette
crise sanitaire
ce soir olivier ferrand va passer
quelques messages selon vous je pense
qu'il va passer un message de déjà de
remerciement et puis de de soutien
également par rapport à cette situation
parce que c'est qu'il ya des membres des
personnels hospitaliers mais il ya aussi
des familles qui seront qui seront
présentes donc il ya aussi je pense
le cette envie de remercier aussi les
les personnes qu'ils se sont investis
pour cette crise et qui dit continuer à
s'investir parce que on le voit elle
durera encore de longs mois
le ségur de la santé 1 qui s'achève avec
cet accord vous sur la revalorisation
des salaires des personnels soignants
des ehpad également vous soutenez vous
cet accord oui moi je soutiens cet
accord je pense qu'effectivement depuis
très longtemps les soignants particulier
hospitalier se plaignaient de de
conditions de travail difficiles et
aussi le travail de salaire rémunération
assez en comment dire là c'est assez
sous-estimé par rapport à la moyenne des
17 des rémunérations qu'on connaît dans
les pays de l'europe et 1 et donc je
crois que cette opération était
nécessaire il appelle maman passer par
une crise sanitaire catastrophique qui a
montré que la santé c'était sûrement
être bien peu plus le plus fondamental
et que du coup il fallait prendre soin
d'eux aussi de ces soignants et qui
mérite est d'avoir une rémunération à
hauteur de leur investissement et je
crois que voilà c'est à peu près 200
euros 200 euros d'augmentation pour les
soignants hospitalier fois qu'elle est
bienvenue on lui demandait des syndicats
demandent et 300 euros dont ils ont eut
ils ont dû 196 c'est déjà une bonne
chose et ils sont tous que ça vient
pérenniser donc l'augmentation des
revenus parce qu'ils avaient d'une
première prime 1 2500 euros évidemment
bienvenus mais je crois qu'il fallait
absolument
[Musique]
comment dire augmenter façon pérenne la
rémunération des soignants etc c'est une
bonne chose
bon ça va sachant que c'est pour le
personnel hospitalier et des goûts on
travaille en ville et pour la vie pour
l'instant il a pas eu d'augmentation de
la libération des actes ambulatoire est
ce qu on note aussi c'est que demain il
devrait y avoir une journée d'action à
l'appel de la cgt de sud de plusieurs
organisations syndicales qui demandent
une augmentation plus forte plus
importante en tout cas ils sont pas
vraiment d'accord avec
le compromis trouvé dans le cadre de
ségur de la santé on a le sentiment là
que quelque part ça divise aussi les
personnels soignants
oui je pense que c'est bien comme comme
souvent fait il ya toujours 2 2 enfin il
est d'opposer deux postures en fait dans
les revendications par dassault il ya
ceux qui qui dès qu'ils trouvent que
voilà il faut trouver un compromis et
que ne rien 180 euros d'augmentation
mensuelle c'est déjà pas si mal que ça
représente quand même près de 7
milliards d'euros 1 2 de finance
publique à financer c'est de l'argent et
donc il faudra il faudrait le financer
et que dans le contexte actuel sait déjà
c'est déjà pas mal
il ya donc ils ont une posture un peu
plus revendicative et puis d'opposition
va dire et qui eux voulaient absolument
à voir les 300 euros
voilà moi j'étais plutôt partie des gens
qui pensent que c'est déjà pas mal
sachant que tout cas pour pour moi et on
est des conseils de ville on va faire
des libéraux et donc du coup pour nous
cette augmentation n'a pas lieu n'a pas
lieu d'être
demain on m'appelle macron doit devrait
s'exprimer à l'occasion d'une interview
vous en attendez quoi de cette
intervention est par ailleurs il ya une
polémique encore qui dure sur le port du
masque obligatoire pour obligatoire une
tribune justement pour que ce port du
masque est obligatoire dans les lieux
publics clos
alors concernant eminem mal combat je
pense que il va te faire son discours du
14 juillet dont quand on entend que
j'achète de détails là il va avoir une
bonne posture un peu je pense comme à
olivier ferrand ce soir au dîner au
grand palais d'été dur c'est de
remercier les soignants qui se sont
investis et puis ils continuent à les
soutenir toute la durée de la crise qui
va être encore longue et on le voit bien
avec lesquin qui acquit qui
ressurgissent par ci par là son
territoire qui avec qui nous inquiète et
qui inquiète et sociales de santé à
juste titre d'ailleurs je pense que
c'est pour ça qu'il ya une tribune qui
est qui est paru avec des noms de deux
professeurs des hôpitaux et qui
s'inquiètent et et à juste titre parce
que le le port du masque on le voit avec
l'été avec le fait que les gens ben on
en a on peut comprendre aussi un petit
peu et ben et que l'écart recul m
évidemment et bien que du coup il ya un
peu moins de prix de dubaï à la prise de
conscience un peu diminué et est du coup
voilà les gestes barrière s'efface un
peu et du coup leur idée de rendre le
masque obligatoire comme on a rendu les
vaccins obligatoires parce que certains
comportements tels que du coup on était
on prenait des risques pour l'ensemble
de la société
ce sera peut-être nécessaire
effectivement d'en arriver à ce type de
mesures est merci à vous qu elle vienne
mal à carmat vous êtes un président
fondateur groupement action soins
infirmiers sion